hey everybody welcome to ultimate
coaster X this is a free coaster
simulator that came out on Steam a few
days ago and there are a couple of
things that I do want to know about this
this is an early access game and it's
built by only one person so don't make
your expectations too high but I still
think that this is worth looking into
especially because it's free and it also
has VR support so if you have a VR set
and you're interested in coming up with
your own coasters and riding them I
think this game works out quite well and
I think really one of the major selling
points that it has is for me at least
that it has an amazing coaster creator
which is honestly one of the best
coaster builders that I've ever seen it
kind of hits a balance between planet
coaster and the limits I think it's much
more accurate realistic and smooth than
the planet coaster coaster builder but
it's easier and maybe even more
intuitive than the no-limits one
although of course it has a lot less
options and a lot less control over what
you do with your coasters than their
limits it's nowhere near as professional
as a tool as that is being just a
one-man project but still it's really
worth looking into it's a very
impressive game for a one-man project
now some of the things which you might
be able to see our not as well developed
is the UI which is quite simple the
camera controls are a bit clunky the
game is still a bit buggy and aside from
the kosis of themselves there's not a
lot to the game there's some basic
terrain editing tools as you can see and
there are two trees which are some of
the worst trees that I've ever seen so
it's not as great in that respect but
it's still an early access game so a lot
can still change what's really kept my
hopes up is that the game has been
updated quite a bit already even though
it's only been out on Steam for a few
days the developer has taken in a lot of
constructive criticism and updated it
quite a few times and yeah I have to say
this is a beta version which you can see
running over here and I don't know how
much is already in the public release as
well but even in just this beta version
in the last couple of days there's been
the addition of an undo button strict
nodes which I'll get back to that later
and there's even steam support now which
is really cool and something that the
game didn't originally come with so yeah
really there's a lot of potential here
is what I'd say in general but really
the star of the show is the coaster
builder so for this video I want to keep
the focus on the coaster builder just to
let you know how that works and so you
can see whether this would be something
for you or not so what I've been
thinking to do is to start a time lapse
where I build my own first full layout
coaster because even though I've messed
with the controls and trying to get used
to them I haven't built a full layout
yet but before that I just want to
explain really quickly so you can
clearly see how they work what the
coaster builder mechanics are so if you
want to build a coaster you basically
start a new track over here and then you
can see that the UI is very simple but
once you start to get a reading of how
this works
it works quite well I think here you can
see all the different types of coaster
types that you can use the book spines
are B&M scooter is intamin and then
there are some wooden RMC and arrow and
and slc options I'm just gonna go for an
intimate coaster for now and then the
way that you build track is not piece by
piece like it would be in planet coaster
for instance it's a bit more similar to
no limits but you are doing everything
in this 3d space live so I can place a
control point here and then if I place
another one here it's gonna build a
track section and that's basically how
it works now this is pretty long so I'm
gonna make that a bit shorter maybe
about 60 meters that's gonna be my
station and then if I want to continue
from there I can hold shift to raise the
control point up and down and I can hold
zet to make it in a straight line so if
I combine those two things I can
basically make sure that I got a
straight lift tool like this so I'm just
gonna build one large straight section
here and top that off at the end here
yeah that looks about right now you can
always mess quite a bit with the shaping
because you can just grab these control
points and manipulate them in an
that you like so for instance here you
can make this note strict to make sure
that it's straight and this is why the
addition of strict nodes is absolutely
awesome and I love it and then if you
want to build curves and things like
that you just let go of the set key and
raise your note up and down and just
place it wherever you like and even
though it's super simple and really
there's not a lot of UI to it I really
like the blue line that you get that
sort of draws to the ground and shows
you very clearly where you are building
because it makes it very easy to build
curves so if I want to have a curving
drop for instance all I do is just lower
these control points and there you go
that's a little and the first curve drop
I'm actually gonna expand that a little
bit just because I think the end of the
lift Hill isn't quite good there
something like that should be good don't
want to add an extra note there and yeah
that is that is a first drop basically
and it automatically smoothes out as
well because it only renders the track
after you're done building so as you can
see the track doesn't exactly follow the
notes it just sort of follows the path
of least resistance and you can
manipulate the tracks in many other ways
so for instance get banking and track
types and supports so for the banking
for instance you place very similar
control points so I'm wanted to be zero
percent on the lift Hill so I'm gonna
select zero there but then for this drop
I do want to have some mild banking so
I'm gonna place a point here
make it bank thirty degrees something
like that that should be fine and now
the track section is banked as you can
see actually maybe I want to raise that
up a little bit yeah there we go
and then what we can also do is to give
tracks different types so to select the
stations rack or chain lifts or even
different types of track in terms of you
know whether it's just a simple flat
track or whether it's a box track we can
put these control points for segments
that will divide the track into
different segments so once you've made
that
the vision we can select this parts the
biggest station track we can select this
to be a chain track and then this is
going to be a three tube standards track
but we can also change that depending on
what kind of you know design you want to
have to it so I would actually go for a
spineless because that's a pretty small
drop so that's gonna make it just a flat
track so if we leave the coaster builder
and renders out the track I've set the
word track too many times in the last
few sentences but it's pretty much an
avoidable and in this context I suppose
and yeah that is basically how you build
coasters here so as you can see it's not
too difficult
I haven't even built my first coaster
layout yet but after a few hours of just
practicing with the tools I think you
can quite easily get the hang of it
obviously you can write them as well
also lets you see if this curve is
actually smooth at all because I didn't
really put any effort into it but yeah
it looks like it's pretty good as you
can see quite smooth so I'm happy with
that so yeah that is basically how the
track builder works and if you really
get good at it
you might be able to build layouts like
this so I'm just gonna go into quick
time-lapse and see if I can come up with
anything good let's go alright so
halfway through the building of this
coaster I realized that I could
reasonably do it in an hour so I decided
to give myself an hour to work on this
and see how far I would get and and
decided to build an intimate mega Lite
coaster just because I really love these
things just because there are such
airtime machines and they're quite small
and not too difficult to build so
probably a good coaster to try first in
the game so what I want to get down
first is the lift hill and this is not
going to be too tall since it's really a
small coaster and then into a drop and a
helix well not quite a helix turn around
I guess very similar to real-life
intimate mega lights they all have the
exact same layout though so I do want to
make this one a bit different it's a bit
smaller as well so I guess I could call
this the intimate mini lights not sure
but very similar to the existing ones it
kind of does a
turn around into an airtime Hill
although in real life this is a twisted
airtime Hill and I didn't really like
that one in real life so I'm just making
this a simple Camelback no banking no
special tricks whatsoever and as you can
see I'm trying to not use too many nodes
and really manipulating the nodes that I
do have as much as possible to get them
into the shapes that I want and to try
and get them to be as smooth as I can
get them at least also within this time
frame I already have to say this is not
a super smooth coaster and you could
definitely do better if you give
yourself more time and trying to tweak
it until it's smooth enough so there
will be some pumps in this but overall I
think it's an acceptable quality and
especially the airtime Hills I think
came out quite alright so moving on from
that first Camelback is another turn
into a double down actually here which
is not too common for these kinds of
things I actually wanted to just make it
another simple airtime Hill but there
was the station right underneath it so I
was kind of forced to do this double
down so I think it's pretty fun not
something you typically see on these
kinds of coasters but can't be too bad I
suppose and then after that's another
airtime Hill here and every now then I
will be testing the coaster so once you
leave the editor it renders out the
track and you can test it and ride it
and especially given that most of the
time you're just staring at weird lines
and splines I do like to do that every
now and then just so you get an idea of
what the coaster is actually going to
look like now my next element here was a
Stengel dive which is quite a nice
intimate elements and then after that I
decided to add in two twisted airtime
Hills and these are really staples of
the original intimate mega light layouts
and I never really saw the appeal of
these things until I wrote the standard
intimate mega light layout myself these
twisted airtime Hills are amazing at
throwing you out of your seat
not just with negative air time but with
laterals as well which is super cool
really like these things so why not put
some in this layout as well kind of you
know make it an all-star layout
some of the best elements of the mega
lights but in a slightly smaller package
I suppose so yeah that is basically the
entire layout and from this point
onwards there's just a bunch of tweaking
and doing some support work as well this
is something which I forgot to point out
in the intro but you can also add
supports to your coaster in this game
although unlike no-limits where you just
kind of place nodes and have to make the
supports all by yourself there's an
automatic support generator and the
manual support generator really just
lets you decide where the supports are
going to be placed but you don't
actually place the individual beams
yourself that said there's quite a bit
of control about this so you can change
the angle at which these supports are
built and you can decide whether there
are two support beams or just one but at
the moments at least you can't get into
more advanced support structures or
horizontal support beams and things like
that so it's a bit basic but it's also
quite easy to use so there's some
upsides and downsides to it I think and
that is pretty much the layout I think
yeah at this point I'm just changing
some of the supports and finally also
doing a little bit of terrain work to
make it seem as if it's actually in a
real setting I tried making some of the
supports thinner over here and then I
realized that Tennant wants to do that
for the whole track so I didn't end up
doing it but realistically if I wanted
to make this a really realistic and so
many mega lights the supports would
probably have to be a little bit thinner
and there would probably have to be more
supports as well the way that the
automatic support generation works it
just places one every 12 meters or every
11 meters I think is what I've set it to
but in real life you'd have more
supports in valleys and low-lying areas
of the coaster and you'd have less
supports at the top of the hills and
things like that just because of how
gravity works I don't know I'm not an
engineer but that's usually how it is so
yeah finally I decided to put it on the
Riverside I didn't want to put it over
the water which I thought of first
because then the footer is kind of
disappear into the water not a big fan
of that
honest but I guess this works at least
make sure that the coaster isn't in the
middle of nowhere now that is pretty
much it for the building process so
let's get back into the game and see
what it looks like all right so here's
the coaster and let's start by actually
just giving it a ride so the cable lift
is pretty fast also that's worth
pointing out you can use a cable lift
instead of a chain into this first curve
not the smoothest but you can definitely
tell that it just transitions a lot
better than planet coaster does for
instance so yeah there was a bit of a
bump on that curve just now but overall
I'm decently happy that was a smooth
curve this Camelback over here is great
Stangl dive is quite smooth bit of a
pump here but yeah most of the right
writes pretty well I think at least for
something that I just put together very
quickly just to try and get used to the
coaster builder now there's a number of
other things which I think are worth
pointing out as well if you're just all
about riding the coasters or if you have
a VR set and you just like checking out
layouts on VR that's fine but if you
care about realism as well you want to
crunch the numbers and I've heard from
the dev that it's not too sure exactly
how OnPoint the numbers are but as far
as I've seen they seem to be pretty
accurate and you can check the speed
throughout different parts of the ride
over here you can check the acceleration
the vertical g-forces and the lateral
g-forces and when you look at the
vertical G's they're they're pretty high
on some parts I mean this is some
decently strong floater at a time but
there's a there's some sustained very
strong ejector here over here as well
and this whole Hill is just almost the
sustained like minus one point three
should be more sustained actually might
want to tighten that a little bit but
yeah overall pretty happy with this
layout of course there's a number of
things which you know would be much
better which I would take the time to do
if I gave enough of a fork to improve
this layout but to be honest I really
for something that was put together for
an hour just to see how intuitive the
game feels how it feels to control the
coaster builder I think it'll do the job
fine and I'm pretty happy with this so
that's all I want to say about ultimate
coaster x4 now if you're interested in
theme park simulation games I highly
recommend that you check this out on
Steam it's free anyway and as for me
I'll be keeping an eye on this game and
I'll probably keep playing it and maybe
in the future when some more updates
come out I'll make some more videos of
it as well we'll see anyway that's it
for today thanks for watching and I will
see you guys next time